Hey. Hey. Hey.
Nice.
Christian.
Hey,
hey, hey.
Hello everyone. Welcome.
Come on in if you're out there. We're
going to get started. My name is
Valerie. My pronouns are she, her, and
we're glad everyone's here tonight. Um,
we just have a couple of announcements.
Next week, don't forget we are having
our Christmas service next week. It'll
be at 5:00 p.m. right here. Um, it's
going to be a family-friendly service.
So, we will have nursery for kiddos for
ages four and under. Otherwise, everyone
else is going to be in the service with
us. We're going to sing carols, have a
candle lighting ceremony. So, please
everyone come join us. Invite friends,
family. It'll be a great time.
We also have a ramp building project
we're going to have the opportunity to
help with. Um, it's going to be on
Saturday, December 20th. If you would
like to volunteer, we need you to sign
up, and you can do that by scanning this
QR code that's right behind me, and that
will give you all the information, and
you can sign up there.
Um, we're kind of going to be embracing
a nice rhythm of a rest. And so on
December 28th, we will not be having any
sort of service. This will be give us a
time for our volunteers to just take a
break and just spend some time at home.
So, we won't have any service then, but
we will be back all together on Sunday,
January 4th.
Finally, if you are feeling anxious
today or you're part of the disability
community or just feeling a little bit
extra fidgety, we have an accessibility
bucket. It's just right over there on
the table to my left. We've got noise
cancelling headphones, fidgets, coloring
sheets. Please help yourself at any
point to the service with any of that.
Um we just ask that you return whatever
you use um back at the end of service.
These candles that are here on either
side of me are a sign of the presence of
Christ,
fully divine and fully human.
Now we exit the kingdom of noise, hurry,
and productivity.
Now we enter the kingdom of silence,
stillness, and simplicity.
sacred space,
a place for prayer, worship, and
adoration.
A place to behold Christ.
Revelation of God, heartbeat of
creation. Allow the unforced rhythms of
grace to find you, to mend your heart.
May we all come home.
Why don't you guys go ahead and stand
with us? We're going to get started.
Caitlyn's going to lead this one for us.
You can hold my hand
when you need to let go.
I can be your mountain
when you're feeling valley low.
I can be your street light
showing you the way home if you can hold
my hand
when you need to let go.
I want a house with a crowded
table and a place by the fire for
everyone.
Let us take on the world while we're
young and able and bring us back
together when the day is done.
If we want a garden,
we're going to have to sew the seed.
Take a little happiness.
Let the roots run deep.
If it's love that we give, then it's
love that we reap. If we want a garden,
we're going to have to sew the seeds.
Yeah. I want a house with a crowded
table and a place by the fire for
everyone.
Let us take on the world while we're
young and able and bring us back
together when the day is done.
The door is always open. Your pictures
on my wall.
Everyone's a little broken. Yeah,
everyone belongs.
Yeah, everyone belongs.
I want a house with a crowded
table and a place by the fire for
everyone.
Let's take on the world while we're
young and able and bring us back
together when the day is done. and
brings us back together when the day
is done.
Oh,
it's done.
All right, kiddos can go to their
classes.
So, so grateful for our kids ministry
people. If you get a chance to thank
them, give them a high five, tell them a
compliment, give them a piece of good
advice that you haven't given anyone
else, do it. They deserve it. They
deserve some some love.
At this time, we are going to do uh
prayers of the people. Uh, and so you
can read along with us up here on the
screen and then there'll be a moment
where we have some silence where you can
say a situation or the name of a person
uh out loud uh for the community to hold
them in the space together.
For the city of Saxi, Texas, and for
every city and community and all who
live in them, we pray to you for the
good earth you have given us and the
wisdom and the will to conserve it. We
pray to you
for the old and the sick, for the widow
and orphan, for the injured and
suffering. We pray to you for the poor
and the oppressed, the unemployed and
destitute, for prisoners and captives
and all who remember and care for them.
We pray to you
for the vulnerable, the marginalized,
and those unjustly targeted for their
gender, sexuality, race, or other
perceived difference. We pray to you
for those experiencing loss, loneliness,
and disconnection. And for those
struggling with mental and emotional
health, we pray to you.
Lord, we know that you love us, that you
hear us. So, we lift these names and
situations up to you.
For the names and moments we have spoken
aloud and for those we have kept in our
hearts. We pray to you that they may
have life and light, healing and hope,
peace and a deep sense of your presence.
Amen.
And in my mother's womb,
you formed me with your hands, known in
love by you
before I took a breath. When I doubted,
Lord, remind me I'm wonderfully made.
You're an artist and a part. I'm the
canvas and the clay.
You make all things
work together
for my future
and for my good. You make all things
work together
for your glory
and for your name. Hey,
there's a healing light
just beyond the clouds. Though I've
walked through fire,
I see clearly now. I know nothing has
been wasted.
No failure or mistake. You're an artist
and a heart. I'm the canvas in the clay.
And you make all things
work together
for my future
and for my good. You make all things
work together
for your glory
and for your name.
And when I doubt it, Lord, remind me.
I'm wonderfully made. You're an artist
and a parter. I'm the canvas and the
clay. And I know nothing has been
wasted.
No failure or mistake.
You're an artist and aarter.
I'm the canvas and the clay. I know it.
Lord, remind me I'm wonderfully made.
You're an artist and aarter. I'm the
canist and the clay. And I know nothing
has been wasted.
No failure or mistake. You're in
a potter. I'm the cheers and the clay.
You're not finished with me.
You're not finished with me yet. You're
not finished with me.
not finished with me. No. You're not
finished with me yet.
You make all things
work together
for my future
and for my good. You make all things
work together
for your glory
and for your name.
for your name.
Even when I don't see it, you're
working. Even when I don't feel it,
you're working. You never stop. Never
stop working. You never stop. Never stop
working. Even when I don't see it,
you're working. Even when I don't feel
it, you're working. You never stop.
Never stop working. Never stop.
You are here
moving in our midst.
I worship you.
You are here
working in this place.
I worship you.
You are way maker, miracle worker,
promise keeper, light in the darkness.
My God, that is who you are.
>> You are way maker, miracle worker,
promise keeper, light in the darkness.
My God, that is who you are.
>> You are here
touching every heart.
I worship you.
You are here
healing every heart.
I worship you.
>> You are here
turning lives around.
I worship you.
You are here
many every heart.
I worship you.
I worship you. Oh
you are way maker, miracle worker,
promise keeper, light in the darkness.
My God, that is who you are.
You are way maker, miracle worker,
promise keeper, light in the darkness.
My God, that is who you are.
That is who you are.
Yeah.
That's who you are.
Even when I don't see it, you're
working. Even when I don't feel it,
you're
never stop. Never stop working. Never
stop. Never stop.
Even when I don't see it, you're
working. Even when I don't feel it,
you're working. Never stop. Never stop
working. Never stop. No.
Even when I don't see it, you're
working. Even when I don't feel it,
you're working. Never stop. You never
stop working. Never stop. You never stop
working. Even when I don't see it,
you're working. Even when I don't feel
it, you're working. You never stop. You
never stop working. You never stop. No
way. Maker, miracle worker, promise
keeper, light in the darkness. My God,
that is who you are.
You are way maker, miracle worker,
promise keeper, light in the darkness.
My God, that is who you are.
That is who you are.
>> Even when I don't see it, you're
working. Even when I don't feel it,
you're working.
You're working.
Stop. Stop again.
Mysterious Christ, your ways are higher
than our ways.
Your thoughts are higher than our
thoughts.
There is an entire world of action that
we don't see.
Because we don't see that world of
action, we grow anxious.
We grow fearful.
We grow impatient,
confused, bewildered.
And to trust in you when we don't see
what you're doing is
a daily thing.
So Lord, I pray for
grace upon grace
on every heart with us and not with us.
To trust
in your work and action behind the
scenes.
All the ways you are working for
redemption, for healing,
for wholeness
that we don't see.
Help us to trust.
Help us to try and not figure it all out
or feel like the only way we can believe
is if we can make sense of it.
Soften our hearts
and open our ears, Lord.
We ask this in your name. Amen. Before
you sit down, turn to your neighbor or
if you want to walk all the way across
the room, that's cool, too. Uh, but
let's pass the peace of Christ with each
other.
of grace and peace. Welcome to the
table. So, so good to be with each and
every one of you. And as always, that
includes those joining us online. Love
you all lots. Um, my name is Brett. I'm
the pastor here. Pronouns he, him, and
yeah, it's a joy joy to welcome you into
this space and uh be with you in this uh
this Advent season. So we are uh we are
in Advent and that's our kind of current
series and uh for those unfamiliar you
know Advent is uh it's kind of a
preparation to celebrate Christmas. So
it's not quite the celebration of
Christmas per se that will come up uh
for us a week from today at our
Christmas service. Um this is yeah a
time of kind of heart and mind
preparation as we approach the the
beautiful birth uh of Jesus Christ. And
uh so the title of my message this week
is why isn't God fixing things?
And our gospel reading is Matthew
chapter 11 uh verses 2-6. Although we're
going to begin with just the first few
passages. We'll read the rest uh later
in the in the sermon. So it reads like
this. When John who was in prison heard
about the deeds of the Messiah, he sent
his disciples to ask him, that is right,
Christ, are you the one who is to come
or should we expect someone else?
Now, this is a it's an interesting
uh thing for John to ask here. And I
really appreciate
uh kind of this the beginning the kind
of vulnerability of this beginning of
the the story because here we see this
is a very different John the Baptist
than the one we encountered last week.
Uh for those who are unfamiliar with
John the Baptist, he's like a fire
brand. You know, he's a prophet and he's
like preparing the way for the Lord. you
know, he's like very uh enthused and uh
so last week was I don't know, we might
call it the early John even though it's
just a few years back. Um but you know,
he's early in his ministry and he was
like full of vinegar and fire and uh and
kind of a certain confidence, you know,
and his message then was like basically
it was, you know, it was a message of
repentance. It was a message of like get
serious people, you know, repent. The
Messiah is coming. And if you were here
for the reading last week, he literally
says like and uh well, there's a
paraphrase my own, but basically the
Messiah is coming and he's not going to
mess around. You think I'm intense? No,
I baptize with water. He shall baptize
with fire. You know, like this is like
the early John the Baptist. He's just
like, "Yes, right." Such passion there.
commitment, zeal, you know,
and I think, you know, something like
this vibe. I think this is uh often
true, maybe not of all of us, but many
of us kind of early in our Christian
faith or even if you came to faith later
in life, uh it could be, you know, maybe
like around the time of your baptism or
something, we were just like, "Yes, full
of zeal and passion and fire and you're
like out to convert everyone and you
know what I mean?" Just uh we get kind
of in this um this mode. there's even a
kind of certainty that can happen and uh
and yes even perhaps we get a little
judgy you know of uh of others which I
think certainly John the Baptist could
be maybe accused of you know um pretty
pretty tough on people and you know I um
well one place where this shows up um I
think today is um Bible college. So I
mean I'm speaking out from experience.
So, if you've ever been to like a Bible
school or Bible college or just known
people who were in that season of life,
maybe early in seminary or something,
um, folks often get like this. And, um,
I, yeah, I've definitely met some John
the Baptist types in my own little stint
at Bible colleges. Actually, Bible
college for forever because I got
married young. So, I tell people I
crammed uh, four years of college into
11.
So I was just forever about just class
here and there. So and it was weird too
because I went through my own
deconstruction kind of right through
that and I was like kind of there. I
took a break for a while and it was a
weird I don't know. So I s I've seen you
know I've seen it all. I've been at a
Bible college 11 years let me tell you
you know um and I mean it was
fascinating like it's almost like folks
at Bible college they're they're old
enough you know have some real faith you
know I mean they're not 10 year olds or
something like there's some substance
there. um but not they've often they
tend to be young and there hasn't they
haven't had enough of life to like
really fall on their face you know or to
have that moment both in a life
experience kind of way that kind of
humiliation that comes with just life in
general if you know you know um and or
and also kind of from a faith
perspective where there is you know
they're learning things and it's easier
kind of getting a certain version of the
Bible and and the Christian faith you
know and it's just very easy to lock in
on it and like I've got the truth I got
the truth. And you start gripping it
kind of like this with fists. And you
know what happens when you form fists,
you know, you get prone to like knock
people out who don't agree. You know,
there's just kind of this thing
happening. And uh yeah, I met a lot of
John the Baptist types and uh yeah, it's
like they hadn't quite learned kind of
gone through life enough that um they
were humbled and humiliated and doubting
and maybe even having that experience
which I had uh where you have these
certain things that you're so sure of
only to later in life realize like oh
actually not only was that wrong that
was downright destructive and I probably
hurt some people. Awesome. you know,
it's just so it's not just humbling, it
is humiliating. It's, you know, it will
it will get you. And and I think um
yeah, a lot of the folks I I encountered
there at Bible College, they just hadn't
quite lived enough life yet, you know.
Um years after actually attending um I
won't say which school, but just a
school here in Dallas, I was at a local
coffee shop in Dallas. I think it must
have been in my journey, this long
11-year thing. And so, you know, I was
just there. I don't really have a lot of
reading assistance to be down in Dallas.
So, I'm at this coffee shop and I see
this guy. I mean, I hadn't seen him in
like eight years from the Bible college,
you know, and he's working there. And I
was kind of like, hey, you know, it's
you like what what's up? How have you
been? You know, he's like, "Oh, well."
He said, "Well, I'm working here."
He said, "Not my plan."
And then he said something I'll never
forget. Like this is why I think this
experience kind of stuck out my mind. He
said, "I guess that's what happens
though when you get a BA in BS."
I wasn't sure exactly what all was
behind that. I wasn't sure if just
having a Bachelor of Arts and Bible
hadn't translated well to the job
market, you know, if it was that um or
if it was kind of like a deeper like
he's just out, you know, but there was
like such a intense cynicism and I was
thinking back to who he had been, you
know, that which was like the opposite
of that. He was like all in, you know
what I mean? And it just I mean it it
just completely, you know, struck me. Um
my own path was a bit different. It took
youth ministry to put me through the
ringer. I was a youth pastor for three
years. And um I
I don't know. There's something about
modern youth ministry. I will say I'm
thankful we're really doing our best to
do something different here at the
table. It's much like smaller, more
relational, and I think there's much
beauty there. Um the group I led, it was
very different. Um it was large. Uh
actually to this day it is the largest
church I've ever led was my youth
pastoring
one got Jesse. Um and we had 200
teenagers there on a Wednesday night.
Now some of you are thinking well don't
be so pessimistic but like that's
beautiful. 200 teenagers pursuing the
Lord Jesus Christ,
you know, just weeping. No, no. They
were there to find their next boyfriend
or girlfriend or, you know, I mean, it
was a social scene, pure and simple.
There's about I would say 5% of the
teens that really, you know, I mean,
they were really hungry for spiritual
things that, you know, I mean, but let's
be honest, like this is just what it
was. I really honestly I felt like a
babysitter. I was a babysitter for 200
people and um we did our best to create
a Christ centered atmosphere. I know
there was good that came from it of
course you know still in touch with some
people they were impacted but at the
same time it just put me through the
ring. I was so discouraged. I was
preaching like this, but it was sort of
the early days of cell phones. And I
mean, the teens, they're just on their
phones and like I'm just not. At one
time, Maggie tells a story. Um, she was
just sitting on the front row and all of
a sudden a condom comes flying and just
lands on her lap. Thankfully, unused.
That was a win, I guess. Um, and just
like, what is going on? It was just out
of control. And by the end of the three
years, I was just so discouraged and
just disappointed. And and of course,
not everyone, but certain people around
me were like, "No, but it's beautiful.
Look at all the people and it's because
you're so anointed, you know, and I was
just like,
"No,
if this is what church is, like if this
I just
I mean, by the end of that, that's what
kind of sent me into my deconstruction
journey. I was just like, I got to
figure something out. WE WHAT ARE WE
DOING HERE? WHAT ARE we doing here? You
know, the youth group down the down the
streets passing out Nikes, you know.
HEY, COME ON KIDS. You want some Nikes?
Come to find God. I just God bless. What
are we doing? You know.
Yeah.
Have you um I wonder though like have
you been there maybe in your own way,
you know? I me Bible college or
whatever, but just in your own way, have
you been there in that moment of just so
freaking discouraged? Like just I had a
vision of this is this is what life is
or this is how my life's going to go or
this is what ministry is or this is what
church is or this is, you know, this is
where we need to go and then it's just
like it's all freaking falling apart and
it's so discouraging, you know, and you
wonder just like my friend, you know, is
it all just BS?
you know, whether that's kind of literal
like Christian faith, is it all just BS?
You know, or in a more generic, is life
just a mess? You know what I mean? Like,
is it is it all just BS? So, in other
words, I think it's it's not unusual,
you know, to find ourselves like John
the Baptist
sitting in the cell of our own questions
and doubts and confusions.
You know, you'll uh notice in the
passage that uh John, you know, he's no
longer in the desert, is he preaching to
the masses, you know, being a minor
celebrity of sorts. No, no, no, no. The
the political winds have shifted now.
And they've shifted against him. Now
he's in prison and he's so discouraged.
Like, he's not even sure if Jesus is who
he thought he was. Like how do you get
there from like prepare the way for the
Lord and he's the guy and I'm so
excited. I'm all you know what I mean to
I'm really not I don't even know like is
this I I'm not even I'm not even sure
are you like you the one we should
expect or should it be like someone you
know someone else.
Uh we pick up the story in verse four.
Uh Jesus, this is Jesus' response to
John. When John sends these disciples,
you know, to ask, "Are you the one?"
Jesus replied, "Go back and report to
John what you hear and what you see.
Blind receive sight, the lame walk,
those who have leprosy are cleansed, the
deaf hear, the dead are raised, and the
good news is proclaimed to the poor." He
says this interesting line, "Blessed is
anyone who does not stumble on account
of me."
It's an interesting little ending there,
isn't it? Bless is anyone who does not
stumble on account of me.
What's he getting at? I I think it's
something like this.
The gap between my expectation for how
God works in the world and how God
actually works in the world is much
larger than I'd like to admit.
Maybe you could say like God here seems
to be playing the long game and I am
not. You know what I mean? Like I'm
playing the short game. I need change
and I need it now for for me, for
others, for the world, honestly. You
know, we got to turn this thing around.
Let's get a going. You know what I mean?
In fact, you could even maybe say Jesus
is maybe even just playing the long.
It's like he's just playing like a
different game entirely. You know, like
he's not even trying to win at my game.
And and what is my game? I don't know.
Well, let's start with even the culture.
Just the game of the culture. This is
certainly not a game Jesus is playing.
The game of money, the game of power,
the game of success in the political,
social, and here's where it translates
to church and the religious spheres. You
know, we have our own visions of success
and this is what it looks like and this
is how it should be and this is how
church should be and this is how people
should be and you know, we have our
whole plan and this is what God should
be up to. do is really what God ought to
be doing, you know, and it's just like
not how it is.
There was another time where Jesus was
asked uh what is your kingdom like? Like
what's this? You know, you're talking
about your kingdom. What's it what's it
like? You know, and there was a certain
irony as uh Charles preached on a few
weeks ago with the language of kingdom
and such. There's a certain irony Jesus
using this language of kingdom because
we start imagining like kings with power
and hierarchy and and then Jesus just
completely subverts that you know so he
says what's my kingdom like you know my
kingdom well he said it's like a it's
like a like a little mustard seed it's
like so small but then over time just
give it time it just grows and grows and
grows and grows and grows and before you
know it it's like swallowed up the whole
garden and he said what's uh what's my
what's my kingdom like it's like It's
like yeast and dough. It's like hidden.
You can't you can't even see it. And
just slowly just like works its way
through the dough until before you know
it's all like bubbling and thoroughly
infused. You know,
like in other words, there's this kind
of picture of uh how does the kingdom
work? It's this like subtle quiet
um process. It's like behind the scenes,
you know. And I don't know about you,
but this is not how I want to work,
you know. This is this is not how I want
God to work. I I want like quick results
and I want them I want them now. I want
them now. This is what uh this kingdom
that Jesus came to establish. This is
what uh the theologian Alan Krider, he
called it the patient ferment of the
early church. I like that turn of phrase
patient ferment of the early church. you
can get there kind of the yeast and
dough kind of language with ferment and
you know it's this kind of subtle hidden
uh mysterious kind of process you know
especially for in the ancient world they
didn't really understand how this stuff
is fermenting they just know weirdly it
just does you know it's it's kind of
there's a mystery there and uh if you
look at how the church grew in its first
400 years it really is quite remarkable
because it was all like and think even
specifically just around in and around
Rome it was all like subtle and behind
the scenes and mostly invisible. I mean,
the church just didn't go out courting,
you know, the high and mighty and trying
to basically kind of win the elites and
then by getting the elites in power,
then influence, you know, I mean, the
rest and kind of get everyone else on
board like no, no, it kind of started
there at the bottom, so to speak.
started with the, you know, the lost and
the the meek and the marginalized and,
you know, it was this very different way
of working and and uh and just slowly
through the years um it you know it
grew, right? Like just like like the
yeast and dough like the the little
mustard seed that's so tight you
couldn't if I was holding it you
couldn't even see it and yet it takes
over the whole garden. Like this is how
God works. Obscure, quiet, humble,
patient.
In fact, it's interesting to think. I
wonder if some of John's own wrestlings
were that uh speculating here, but I
wonder if he really wanted Jesus to like
knock out those Romans, you know, or
like really establish like not a
metaphorical spiritual, you know, uh
kind of kingdom, like a literal kingdom
like warriors and you know what I mean?
Like and I wonder if he really wanted
that. And it's it's interesting that uh
in many ways you could say Jesus
ultimately did conquer Rome
back to that patient firmament of the
early church. I mean if you know some of
your church history uh it's it just took
about 400 years and no sword was ever
raised
which is interesting you know instead
actually the Roman leaders they came to
the church and asked for help. Now, we
can argue that at that point they the
church should have said no because
that's the Constantinian compromise and
you got this whole long history of
Christendom and there's a whole thing
you know uh fair enough like you can
name that you know I mean I think that's
a viable they should have said no maybe
um but it is interesting that that in
essence uh Rome wasn't conquered by you
know violent Christian revolutionaries
who just like grabbed power for Christ
you know or something no it was the
leaders begged the church for help. And
that's actually how Rome conquered. You
see,
when we're discouraged by the lack of
spiritual maturity and progress in
ourselves or in the church or in the
broader culture, I I think this is where
we must learn to um start looking for
the signs, you know, inbreakings, little
inbreakings of the kingdom, places where
healing, life, forgiveness, and hope are
happening, right? Because this is what
Jesus said, right? This was his response
to John was, "Let me tell you the signs.
Let me let me tell you what's
happening." Right? There's there's these
places of healing, places of hope,
places of forgiveness. The the poor
being treated rightly. You know what I
mean? Like it's this is the sign that
it's working, that God's up to
something.
But in essence, um, we miss it, right?
Because we're not always looking for
those exact same signs.
I I wonder though um part of my job as
like a pastor is to walk with people and
one thing I just want to name for all of
us is that I see the work of God in you.
Like I know as you're living your life
it's it's hard to see it. You know what
I mean? You're just like I don't think
so.
But that's the beauty. I swear to you I
see it. I see I see those little mustard
seeds. I see the signs of the kingdom
like happening in you. Like it is it is
so clear. I mean one just to pick one
example. I won't pick on like anyone.
I'm not don't worry I'm not going to
suddenly name a name or something. Um
but one for example, one thing I've seen
is so many people come through these
doors with so much unprocessed um
bitterness and anger at God.
And uh and I won't even defend that, you
know, or say like you shouldn't have
been like no, a lot of it was kind of,
you know, there was there was real hurt
there, you know what I mean? So, I'm not
even trying to downplay it. But it was
also true that that anger was eating you
alive.
That bitterness was like robbing you.
And it is so beautiful. I've just seen
this in person after person after person
where over how does it happen? I don't
know. That's the mystery. I don't
exactly know how it's working or what's
going on. But somehow through the I wish
it were weeks I mean or days but it is
years usually through the years it's
like God just starts to do this work.
How it happens I do not know but it is
beautiful and holy and good and I see it
happening in you. I see it in sweet
Vicky Ferris.
Uh many of you knew her. Um the the
woman who was here with usually had the
walker and the blue hair or different
color hair. Um just a lovely lovely
woman. and uh she passed away last week
and um you know I don't think or I know
she she was well she was not only a
beloved member of our community but I
know she didn't think of herself as like
extraordinary in any way you know or
like special or she just did she did not
um but if you knew her you know she
absolutely was like she was on this uh
journey it was Parkinson's is ultimately
um what just kind of broken her body and
Uh, and she was working, you could just
tell, so hard like not to get just
embittered
and deeply just pessimistic and like she
was and and if you encountered her, you
knew like she had how how a certain joy
about her. You know what I mean? Like a
kind word for others like in the midst
of this just decimating disease. Like
unbelievable. It's incredible. I've seen
the same thing in her daughter Whitney.
And I did get her permission to share
this by the way. This um that the
journey she's been on like caring for
her mother really these last few years,
especially the last few months though,
where she's really stepped up to walk
with her. And if you know Whitney and
some of her story, like she was a wild
child growing up. Um wild. You can ask
her for she'll tell you some amazing
stories. Um, and it's incredible to see
like how that kind of fierceness
and uh and really honestly kind of wild
like courage was been like kind of
funneled into this kind of fierce
commitment and love for her mother and
her children.
And to see her walk that out the last
months and especially the last few weeks
like has been incredible. Like that's
like that's it. That's that's the little
imbreings. That's the the signs, right?
Look for the little look for the
healing. Look for the hope. Look for the
forgiveness. Look for the mercy. Look
look for the compassion. Like just start
to notice where it's happening. Uh one
last example I'll share because this
isn't limited to the table of course is
that every other year we attend uh many
of us here and it actually be coming up
in October. So I encourage you all to
attend. It's the Centerpiece Conference
uh hosted by an organization called
Centerpiece, which is a basically kind
of an LGBTQ affirming um uh ministry
that's trying to really connect with
church folks, people who've been hurt by
the church and the LGBTQ community. It's
run by Sally Gary. Yeah, we have her
picture up there. Uh some of you know
Sally and uh she was basically when she
started this organization like 20 years
ago, she was pretty much a lone voice in
the Churches of Christ kind of
denomination
basically naming like hey
we we got an issue here. like th this is
these these you know gay kids and
lesbian kids and um trans kids like and
people like this isn't some like issue
out there somewhere abstractly in the
world or something like she basically
just named for the church like this is a
sort of uncrunchable truth for them. She
said this is us. It is us. We're not
talking about them. this is our children
and the people in our small groups and
in in you our Sunday school classes and
sitting next to us in our sanctuary like
this is us and we we need to acknowledge
this and and she just I mean was so
incredibly courageous to step out and
start this movement and now I'm at that
conference and it's every other year and
I'm there and I just can't believe
there's like five to 600 people gathered
and the like the energy in that room the
passion the love. It is incredible. And
I just the multiple times I've been
there now, I just stand there on like
the opening night and I'm like, I can't
believe it. Like, how is God doing this
thing? This this is incredible. And here
in Texas, like I'm like, this is a
miracle. It's I mean, it's just another
example of just a little embreaking.
Just a little embrace. this light bursts
forth, this love bursts forth, this this
uh compassion,
this healing, it starts to happen and
it's just beautiful, beautiful,
beautiful to witness, right? It's a sign
of the kingdom. And uh in closing
though, like I get it, right? Life beats
us up. Um like John, man, we just get
beat down and we're just discouraged.
Many of you are there tonight. you're
just just flat out discouraged and
as Jesus kind of named uh we stumble,
you know, we stumble, we doubt, we're
just like, I'm just not sure about, you
know, any of this and we become
frustrated with the slowness, the
slowness of the growth and the
transformation in ourselves, in the
church, in the world. And yet, it's
beautiful. Jesus is so gentle in his
response to us. Which is why in Matthew
11, you'll notice he didn't what did he
not say to John or well to John's little
followers that you know sending the
message. I'm going to take it back to
him. He didn't tell them like, "Well,
you tell John I absolutely am the
Messiah and he better not doubt again."
You know, like no, no, no. This is this
is not how Jesus responds, right?
Instead, what do you say? You tell John,
just tell him what you see and tell him
what you hear.
Look at the healing. Look at the
cleansing. Look at how the lowly and the
marginalized are treated. And listen,
listen to the forgiving and loving
speech. This is what it looks like when
God is at work. So, how does the kingdom
happen? How does it how does it happen
in in my life and our in our church and
the societ broader society? How does it
happen? Well, slowly.
You say, why slowly? Well, because the
other option is quickly, which is to say
coercively, forcefully, violently,
and that's not how God has chosen to
work. We might say that this this love
the kingdom, it moves at the pace of
relationship,
right? Both God's relationship to us, us
and our relationship to others. And so,
I say, "Thanks be to God." You know,
thanks be to God. That's the kind of
Messiah Jesus was. It's the kind of
kingdom he initiates. God is patient.
Oh, patient. Patient with me. Patient
with the church or the broader culture.
I think our job is just to take a deep
breath
and trust. Trust that God is at work. In
the name of the Father, the Son, and the
Holy Spirit. Amen.
So on the night Jesus was betrayed, he
had one final meal with his disciples.
And at that meal, he held a little of
bread and he broke it. And he said,
"Take this, eat it. This is my body.
It's broken for you."
And then he held up a cup of wine. He
said, "Take this drink. This is my
blood. It's shed for you. Whenever you
eat this bread, whenever you drink this
cup, remember me."
And so as we come forward tonight,
that's what we're doing. We're
remembering and in a mysterious way,
we're participating in the Christ who
has promised to be present uh to us in
this bread and cup. And so I encourage
you as you come forward to uh come with
that that kind of an expectation to
receive something to receive a little
encouragement, receive a little life
healing, a little little embracing of
the kingdom for uh for you. So, uh, the
way we'll go about this is we'll just go
rowby row, starting here at the front,
forming a line here in, uh, in the
middle. We practice an open table. So,
if you're here tonight, you want to
participate, feel free to do that
regardless of your exact, you know,
beliefs or theology or denomination or
whatever. Um, if you want to come
forward and receive and connect with
Christ in this way, then do that. Just
know the red is wine, the white is grape
juice. And finally, you can just partake
whenever and however uh you'd like. No
one will lead you through the exact
moment of taking. So this is the table
not of the church
but of the Lord. And it's made ready for
those who love him and for those who
want to love him more. So come. You who
have much faith and you who have little.
You who have been here often and you who
have not been here long. You who have
tried to follow and you feel like you
failed. Come. Come because it's the Lord
Jesus himself who invites you. And it's
his will that those who want to meet him
should meet him here. Come to the table.
If you'd like to join us as we stand to
close, we're going to close with Way
Maker.
I think singing these words together as
we leave will be good.
Even when I don't see it, you're
working. Even when I don't feel it,
you're working. You never stop. You
never stop working. Never stop. You
never stop working. Even when I don't
see it, you're working. Even when I
don't feel it, you're working. You never
stop. Never stop working. Never stop.
Never stop.
Way maker, miracle worker, promise
keeper, light in the darkness. My God,
that is who you are.
You are way maker, miracle worker,
promise keeper, light in the darkness.
My God. That is who you are.
That is who you are.
Thank you so much for joining us this
evening. If you're new, we would love
for you to fill out a card for us. It's
on the table here to my left on your way
out. or also you can scan the QR code
which would be coming up on the screen
behind me.
If you call the table home but you don't
currently serve on a ministry team, we
would love to have you try one out. Tech
team, kids ministry, host team are
currently the ones that are in the most
need. So you can fill out a table on the
card again to my left or also scan that
QR code.
Generosity is a key aspect of a life of
adoration and worship. If the table is
your church home, then we would invite
you to scan that QR code and give
financially or you can also give by
visiting tabletx.org.
All right, let me send to you into your
week with this blessing. You can hold
out your hands and posture to receive or
just open your heart.
You are a child of God.
You are a child of God. This is true on
your best day and it is true on your
worst.
So as you go into your week with its yet
to be determined highs and lows and
everything in between, go filled with
the assurance that you are loved,
you are worthy, and you are accepted
just as you are.
and go filled with God's Holy Spirit and
the desire to extend these same gifts of
grace and unconditional love to everyone
you come into contact with. Thanks
everyone.
>> You are way maker, miracle worker,
promise keeper, light in the darkness.
My God, that is who you are.
>> You are way maker, miracle worker,
promise keeper, light in the darkness.
My God. That is who you are.
That is who you are.
That is who